Hello, beautiful nerds. This week we're re-broadcasting one of my favorite episodes of the last few years about Sears Holmes. I liked it so much that I put it as a piece of bonus content on the audio version of the book that Kurt and I wrote last year. Speaking of, our first book, the 99% Invisible City, came out one year ago this week. It peaked at number three on the New York Times bestseller list and we were really excited about that. If you're into the show at all
你好，可爱的书呆子们。本周我们将重播过去几年中我最喜欢的一集，关于西尔斯住宅（Sears Homes）。我非常喜欢这一集，甚至把它作为我和库尔特去年合著那本书的音频版中的额外内容。说到这里，我们的第一本书《99%隐形城市》（The 99% Invisible City）在本周刚好出版一周年。它曾登上《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜第三名，我们对此感到非常兴奋。如果你对这个节目感兴趣的话，
I think you'll love the book It's also a good gift for folks who are not into podcasts yet But like this kind of nerdy stuff and if you're an audiobook person you can listen to me read it to you for 10 and a half hours Which people seem to dig we're on our semi annual retreat this week where we look back at all the episodes We've made and how we want to shape the show in the future. So thank you for affording us this time to do that. We have a barn burner of a new episode next week. It's all about a flag,
我想你也会喜欢这本书。对于那些还没开始听播客，但喜欢这类书呆子内容的人来说，它也是一份不错的礼物。如果你是听书爱好者，你可以听我为你朗读，全长十个半小时，大家似乎都很喜欢。本周我们正在进行半年一次的务虚会，回顾我们制作过的所有节目，并思考未来如何塑造这个节目。所以，感谢你们给予我们时间来做这件事。下周我们有一集非常精彩的新节目，是关于一面旗帜的，
so we'll be right back in our wheelhouse in no time. In the meantime, please enjoy this story for the first time, or even listen again. It is worth it, listening again. Thanks. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About eight weeks ago, one of the producers here at 99PI ordered a book. Our office receives a lot of books, but this one, this one was special. Everyone wanted to read it.
所以我们很快就会回到我们擅长的领域。在此期间，请第一次欣赏这个故事，或者再听一遍。再听一遍是值得的。谢谢。这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible），我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。大约八周前，我们《99PI》的一位制片人订购了一本书。我们的办公室经常收到很多书，但这一本，这一本很特别。每个人都想读它。
Okay, so first of all, this book is beautiful. I know, it's been- Only it wasn't just any book. That's the producer Joe Rosenberg. It was a catalog. Oh my god, it's from 1908. Catalog number 177 of the great price maker. Wow, there's so much stuff.
好吧，首先，这本书很漂亮。我知道，它已经——只是它不仅仅是一本书。那是制片人乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）。它是一本目录。天哪，它是1908年的。伟大的价格制定者（Price Maker）的第177号目录。哇，里面有太多东西了。
The Sears Enduro book, Mail Order catalog, was nearly omnipresent in early 20th century American life. In 1908, when this particular issue came out, one out of every five Americans were already subscribers. So, is this kind of like the Amazon warehouse before the Amazon warehouse? Yes. Anyone, anywhere in the country could order this catalog for free, look through it, and
西尔斯·罗巴克（Sears Roebuck）的邮购目录在20世纪初的美国生活中几乎无处不在。1908年，当这一期出版时，每五个美国人中就有一个已经是订阅者了。那么，这有点像亚马逊仓库出现之前的亚马逊仓库吗？是的。全国任何地方的任何人都可以免费订购这本目录，翻阅它，然后
then have anything their heart desired delivered directly to their doorstep, like seriously, anything. Parasolus and pipes. Really fancy looking belts. Lost stretch fountains. The world's best. Lost stretch fountains. Oh, headstones. At its height, the Sears Catalog offered over 100,000 items
把你心仪的任何东西直接送到家门口，真的，任何东西。遮阳伞和烟斗。看起来非常时髦的腰带。洛斯特里奇（Lostretch）喷泉。世界上最好的。洛斯特里奇喷泉。哦，墓碑。在鼎盛时期，西尔斯目录提供了超过10万种商品，
on 1,400 pages. It weighed four pounds. Today, those 1,400 pages provide us with a snapshot of American life in the first decade of the 20th century. 1596, our new William Specials single strap buggy harness. What is it? It's a sheep shearing machine.
印在1400页的纸上。它重达四磅。今天，这1400页为我们提供了20世纪第一个十年美国生活的一个缩影。1596，我们新的威廉特别款单带马车挽具。那是什么？那是一台剪羊毛机。
The administration products have definitely evolved. The Sears catalog tells the tale of a world, itemized. But starting with this very issue, in 1908, the company that offered America everything began offering what just might be the most audacious and in some ways most necessary item of all. Wait, these are houses. On page 596, Sears subscribers would come across a drawing of a house. Two stories, nine rooms, gabled roofs, and a price, $1,700. Wait, $1,700 for... No, I think the whole...
行政产品确实进化了。西尔斯目录讲述了一个被逐项列出的世界的故事。但从1908年的这一期开始，这家为美国提供一切的公司开始提供可能最胆大，在某些方面也是最必要的一件商品。等等，这些是房子。在第596页，西尔斯的订阅者会看到一幅房子的图纸。两层楼，九个房间，人字形屋顶，价格1700美元。等等，1700美元买……不，我想整个……
For the house? Seen. Yeah. From 1908 to 1940, the Sears Modern Home Program offered complete, full-size, male-order houses to the Woodbeam homeowner. What would come to be called, kid homes. Sears actually provided an entirely separate catalog for these kid homes, featuring dozens of different designs.
买房子？看到了。是的。从1908年到1940年，西尔斯现代住宅计划（Sears Modern Home Program）为有木梁的房主提供了完整的、全尺寸的邮购房屋。后来被称为“套件住宅”（Kit Homes）。西尔斯实际上为这些套件住宅提供了一本完全独立的目录，里面有几十种不同的设计。
All you had to do was select your preferred model from the catalog, fill out the provided form, send in the check, and a few weeks later, everything you'd need would arrive in a train car. Its door was secured with a small red wax seal, just like the seal on the back of a letter to the gang or something. It was to be broken, only by you. You throw open the door to this box car and you're looking at 12,000 pieces of framing lumber and 20,000 seat or shakes. That's Rosemary Thornton, an architectural historian
你所要做的就是从目录中选择你喜欢的型号，填写提供的表格，寄出支票，几周后，你所需要的一切都会装在一节火车车厢里送达。它的门用一个小红蜡封条封住，就像给帮派写信背面的封条一样。它只能由你自己拆开。你推开这节货车的门，你会看到12000块框架木材和20000块雪松木瓦。那是罗斯玛丽·桑顿（Rosemary Thornton），一位建筑历史学家，
and the author of The Houses that Sears Built. She says that that train car also came with every single door, every single door knob, a fold-away ironing board for your kitchen, even the mantle for the fireplace. And then you would begin the process of dutifully loading it either onto your mule and card or your model T. The lumber came pre-cut, kind of like a giant Ikea set, along with, in true Ikea style, an instruction booklet. If you provided the foundation, Sears promised that working without a carpenter and only rudimentary skills, you could finish your
也是《西尔斯建造的房子》（The Houses that Sears Built）一书的作者。她说，那节火车车厢里还装有每一扇门、每一个门把手、一个厨房用的折叠熨衣板，甚至还有壁炉的壁炉架。然后你就会开始认真地把它装上你的骡车或T型车。木材是预先切割好的，有点像一套巨大的宜家家具，并附有一本宜家风格的说明书。如果你提供了地基，西尔斯承诺，在没有木匠的情况下，仅凭基本的技能，你就能在不到90天内完成你的
Sears mail order home in less than 90 days. Of our rosemary says those instructions also came with a warning. Do not accept anyone's advice on how this house should be built. Follow this instruction manual and do not deviate. So if the old wise encarpenter comes by and says, I wouldn't build it that way and you know, sears this warning you upfront, do not listen to that man. Sears would go on to ship out some 75,000 homes across the country. In doing so, they helped replace the idea that each new house needed to be built from scratch, with the promise that new homes could be standardized, affordable, and within reach of every family. Long before the advent of housing developments in the modern suburb, it was the Sears' kit home that gave
西尔斯邮购住宅。罗斯玛丽说，这些说明书还附带了一个警告。不要接受任何人关于这房子应该怎么盖的建议。遵循这本说明书，不要偏离。所以，如果那个老木匠走过来说，“我不会那样盖”，你知道，西尔斯预先警告过你，不要听那个人的。西尔斯后来在全国范围内运送了大约75000套住宅。在此过程中，他们帮助取代了“每栋新房都需要从零开始建造”的观念，取而代之的是一种承诺：新房可以是标准化的、负担得起的，并且是每个家庭都能触及的。在现代郊区住房开发出现很久之前，正是西尔斯的套件住宅给了
Americans their first taste of 20th century domestic life. But it's also a chapter of housing history that was almost lost. Sears was not the first company to offer kid homes, nor even the first mail order catalog. But it came to dominate mail order because its founder, Richard Sears, was that thing that so many people would claim to be over the course of the 20th century. But very few actually were. He was a marketing genius. He just did so many things. And one of my favorites is that Sears knew that most farm households would have both the Montgomery Ward and the Sears Robot Catalog in the household. So he purposefully made his catalog just a little bit less wide and a little bit less tall than the Montgomery Ward catalog,
美国人对20世纪家庭生活的第一次体验。但这也是住房史上几乎被遗忘的一章。西尔斯并不是第一家提供套件住宅的公司，甚至也不是第一家邮购目录公司。但它之所以能主导邮购业务，是因为它的创始人理查德·西尔斯（Richard Sears）是那种在20世纪有很多人自称是，但实际上很少有人能做到的人。他是一位营销天才。他做了很多事情。我最喜欢的一点是，西尔斯知道大多数农户家里既有蒙哥马利·沃德（Montgomery Ward）的目录，也有西尔斯·罗巴克的目录。所以他特意把自己的目录做得比蒙哥马利·沃德的目录稍微窄一点、矮一点，
knowing that when the farmhouse wife was tidying things up, she would naturally put the Sears Robot catalog on top of the Montgomery Ward catalog. I love that. By 1907, Sears and Robot was selling the then equivalent of $1.3 billion of merchandise to American families every year. And it's around this time that Richard Sears saw a way to sell even more. Most American families were still living in multi-generational housing.
他知道当农场主太太在整理东西时，她会自然而然地把西尔斯·罗巴克的目录放在蒙哥马利·沃德的目录上面。我喜欢这个。到1907年，西尔斯·罗巴克每年向美国家庭销售的商品价值相当于现在的13亿美元。就在这个时候，理查德·西尔斯看到了销售更多商品的方法。大多数美国家庭仍然住在多代同堂的房子里。
The reigning paradigm of the middle class was the Victorian home, with its many little rooms divvying up children, uncles, and grandparents. Sears looked at this idyllic scene of families living in harmony and saw a wasted opportunity. Why should newlyweds move into old homes with old things when they can move into new homes and fill them with new things from Sears? And thus, the Sears modern home program was born. And it was a hit, particularly Sears Modern Home Program was born. And it was a hit, particularly after the end of World War I. When the influx of returning veterans triggered a need for more housing.
中产阶级的主流模式是维多利亚式住宅，有许多小房间，把孩子、叔叔和祖父母分开。西尔斯看着这幅家庭和谐相处的田园诗般的场景，看到了一个被浪费的机会。为什么新婚夫妇要搬进有旧东西的旧房子，而他们可以搬进新房子，并用西尔斯的新东西填满它们呢？于是，西尔斯现代住宅计划诞生了。它非常成功，特别是在第一次世界大战结束后，当归来的退伍军人涌入引发了对更多住房的需求时。
And there was literature that said, if you really love this country, if you really want to do right by America, by a house, build a house, and that's when Kit Holmes really took off. Sears cut the lumber for almost all of these homes ready to order in giant mills situated across the country. The largest in Carole Illinois at the confluence
当时有文献说，如果你真的爱这个国家，如果你真的想为美国做点好事，就买一栋房子，盖一栋房子，那时套件住宅真的火了起来。西尔斯在全国各地的巨大工厂里为几乎所有这些住宅切割好了木材，随时可以订购。最大的工厂位于伊利诺伊州的凯罗（Cairo），在密西西比河和俄亥俄河的交汇处，占地近40英亩，它运出的住宅种类之多令人震惊。第一本现代住宅目录有40多种型号可供选择，但西尔斯最终提供了447种不同的设计。目录中的每一栋房子都有一个符合其建筑抱负的名字。所以，如果你一直梦想住在加州教会风格的房子里，但你无法搬到加州，你可以考虑购买西尔斯的阿罕布拉（Alhambra）型号。
of the Mississippi and Ohio rivers covered nearly 40 acres, and the sheer variety of homes it shipped out was staggering. That first modern homes catalog had over 40 models to choose from, but Sears would go on to offer 447 different designs. Every house in the catalog had a name fitting its architectural aspirations. So if you always dreamed of living in a California mission style home but you couldn't actually move to California, you might consider purchasing Sears Alhambra model.
其他风格包括工匠风格的威诺纳（Winona）和荷兰殖民地风格的玛莎·华盛顿（Martha Washington）。它们的范围从我所说的“猎人小屋”（实际上是两三百美元的两室住宅）到西尔斯的木兰（Magnolia）型号，面积为2900平方英尺，楼上有两个完整的浴室，楼下一个半浴室，两个完整的壁炉，一个书房，甚至还有仆人房和仆人专用浴室。西尔斯甚至提供了一所六间教室的校舍，配有礼堂和图书馆，
Other styles included the craftsman style Winona and the Dutch Colonial Martha Washington. They range from everything from what I would call a Hunter's Cabin, literally a two-room house for two or three hundred dollars to the Sears Magnolia, which was 2,900 square feet, two full bathrooms upstairs, a half bathroom downstairs, two full fireplaces, a den, even had servants quarters and a servants' private bath. Sears even offered a six-classroom schoolhouse, complete with an auditorium and library,
但主要是住宅。又大又漂亮又空旷的房子。等着被东西填满。事实上，如果你看一些旧的平面图，它会标出客厅、餐厅、卧室，然后它会说，放留声机的地方，放钢琴的地方，放两把结实椅子的位置。所以他是在向人们展示如何用西尔斯·罗巴克目录里的东西来塞满他们的房子。消费者也照做了。有一些关于首次购房者的故事，他们购买了你可能称之为“交钥匙工程”的东西，
but mostly it was homes. Big, beautiful, empty homes. Just waiting to be filled with things. In fact, if you look at some of the old floor plans, it'll feature the living room, the dining room, the bedrooms, but then it will say, place for a graphophone, spot for a piano, place for two tough-ded chairs. And so he was kind of showing people how to stuff their houses with stuff from the Sears Robot catalog. And consumers obliged. There are tales of first-time homeowners who bought what you might call a turnkey operation
从目录里买的。房子、家具，以及放在家具上的许多小东西，一种家庭生活，全部来自西尔斯。部分原因是该公司利用其相当精明的营销手段，明确表示建造你的房子将是容易的。有了预先设计的房子，你就不需要建筑师了。有了预先切割的木框架，你也不需要木匠了。你可以把它当作任何其他消费品来对待。西尔斯甚至在目录的前面有这样一个广告。
from the catalog. The house, the furniture, and the many little things that rested on the furniture, a home life, all from sears. In part because the company used its considerable marketing savvy to make it clear that building your house was going to be easy. With a pre-designed home, you didn't need an architect. And with the pre-cut lumber frame, you didn't need a carpenter either. You could treat it like any other consumer item. Sears even had this ad in the front of the catalog.
它展示了两个罗德萨（Rodeza）型号，这是西尔斯最受欢迎的房子之一，并排建造。一个是基本上从零开始建造的，使用普通的建筑材料和未切割的木材，另一个是用预先切割的木材。在广告中，用普通木材建造的房子还没盖完。人们瘫倒在前院，精疲力竭。而那个用预先切割木材建造的房子，
It showed two rodesa models, one of Sears most popular houses being built side by side. One was built from scratch essentially, using ordinary building materials and uncut stick lumber, the other with pre-cut lumber. In the ad, the house with the stick lumber sits unfinished. People are collapsed in the front yard, exhausted. And then the house, where it was built with a pre-cut lumber,
他们坐在门廊上喝着薄荷朱利酒，你知道，过着他们一生中最美好的时光。所以，虽然很多人确实雇了承包商来建造他们的西尔斯住宅，但很多人没有。我听过很多关于家庭收到他们的套件住宅，并呼吁邻居帮助他们出来开始建造房子的过程的故事。
they're sitting on the porch with a mint jewel up, you know, having just the time of their life. And so, all the many people did hire a contractor to build their sears home? Many did not. And I have heard many stories about families receiving their kid home and calling on neighbors to help them come out and start the process of building the house.
对于许多家庭来说，这些是他们第一次拥有中央供暖和隔热设施的房子。在一些社区，西尔斯的套件住宅可能是街区里唯一通电的房子。1911年，西尔斯开始向客户提供有竞争力的抵押贷款，这也帮助有色人种社区的人们绕过了“红线政策”（redlining）。红线政策意味着银行家和抵押贷款机构会在他们不愿贷款的社区周围画一条线。
For many families, these were their first homes with things like central heating and insulation. In some neighborhoods, a Sears kid home might be the only house on the block with electricity. And in 1911, Sears began offering competitive mortgages to their customers, which also helped people in neighborhoods of color get around the practice of redlining. And redlining just meant that the bankers and the mortgage lenders would draw a line around neighborhoods where they would not loan money.
所以西尔斯没有做任何那种事，这使得移民、有色人种男女，以及原本永远没有机会成为房主的单身女性，第一次拥有了室内管道设施。但后来公司发现它犯了一个错误。一个听起来可能太熟悉了的错误。从一开始，西尔斯就确保他们的抵押贷款政策就像他们目录里的其他东西一样，是可获得的。申请表只有半页长，几乎每个申请抵押贷款的人
So Sears didn't do any of that, and that enabled immigrants, men and women of color, and single women who would otherwise never have a chance of becoming a homeowner to have indoor plumbing for the first time. But then the company discovered that it had made a mistake. One that will probably sound all too familiar. From the beginning, Sears had made sure their mortgage policy was like everything else in their catalog, obtainable. The application form was only half a page long and almost everyone who applied for a mortgage
都符合条件，这意味着普通的西尔斯房主也欠西尔斯的债。在咆哮的二十年代，当利率低、流动性高时，这不是问题。但当大萧条来袭时，情况迅速恶化。该公司最终取消了成千上万名客户的抵押品赎回权。我的意思是，这是一种情感上的毁灭。我们都知道大萧条因为很多原因而可怕。但失去一栋你用自己的双手建造的房子，
qualified, meaning that the average Sears homeowner was also in debt to Sears. In the Roaring Twenties, when interest rates were low in liquidity high, it wasn't a problem. But when the Great Depression hit, things got ugly fast. The company ended up foreclosing on tens of thousands of its very own customers. I mean, it was an emotional devastation. We all know the Great Depression was horrible for so many reasons. But losing a home that you had built with your own two
似乎就像在伤口上撒盐。对西尔斯来说，这是一场公关灾难。罗斯玛丽记得在2003年与某人交谈，他描述了西尔斯如何在1931年取消了他祖父母房子的抵押品赎回权。正是西尔斯十年前卖给他们的那栋房子。他说，两代人以来，我们的家庭再也没有光顾过西尔斯。我的意思是，从1931年到2003年，这种感觉太强烈了。在经历了多年的销售下滑后，西尔斯终于在
hands just seems like such a twist of the knife. For Sears, it was a PR disaster. Rosemary remembers talking to someone in 2003 who described how Sears had foreclosed on their grandparents' home in 1931. The very same home, Sears had sold them a decade earlier. And he said, for two generations, our family never patronized Sears ever again. I mean, those are strong feelings to go from 1931 to 2003. After years of declining sales, Sears would finally close its modern homes department in
1940年关闭了其现代住宅部门。其他几家没有出售抵押贷款的套件住宅制造商幸存了下来。但西尔斯的套件住宅热潮结束了。接着是第二次世界大战，随之而来的是以郊区兴起和预制住宅为特征的现代住房热潮。也就是我们今天许多人居住的房子。与此同时，大多数西尔斯住宅，阿罕布拉、阿吉尔（Arguile）、木兰，最终被卖给了新主人，他们不知道自己买了什么，也不在乎去了解。
1940. A few other kit home manufacturers, ones that hadn't sold mortgages, they survived. But the Sears kit home boom was over. Then came World War II, and with it, the modern housing boom featuring the rise of the suburbs and the prefab home. The homes so many of us live in today. Meanwhile, most of the Sears homes, the Alhambres, the Arguiles, the Magnolias, they ended up being sold to new owners who didn't know what they bought or didn't care to know.
尽管材料质量很高，但几十年来，随着公司与“便利高于质量”联系在一起，没有人愿意承认他们住在西尔斯目录里买来的房子里。这很尴尬。所以很多房子最终被翻新得面目全非。许多被拆毁了。其他的则被简单地遗弃了。至于在哪里可以找到剩下的那些？
Despite the high quality of the materials, over the decades as the company became associated with convenience over and above quality, no one wanted to admit that they lived in a home that came from the Sears catalog. It was embarrassing. So a lot of them ended up being renovated beyond recognition. Many were torn down. Others were simply abandoned. And as for where to find the ones that remain?
不幸的是，第二次世界大战后，在一次企业大扫除中，销售记录被销毁了。所以这些记录丢失了？记录也没了，它们不是丢失，是没了。它们没了。它们在某人的焚烧堆里。所有这些东西都被处理掉了。
Unfortunately, after World War II, during a corporate house cleaning, the sales records were destroyed. So these records are missing? Records have gone, too. They're not as missing, they're gone. They're gone. They're in somebody's burn pile. All that stuff was disposed of.
所以今天找到这些房子的唯一方法真的是一个一个地找。在我采访罗斯玛丽几周后，我去看了一些伊利诺伊州凯罗郊外仅存的西尔斯住宅。那个曾经拥有西尔斯最大工厂的城镇。当我到达那里时，唯一能证明那里曾经有过什么的标志是一条杂草丛生的后路的名字：西尔斯路。通向两栋小房子，两栋西尔斯罗德萨型号，并排坐落着。它们就是那则原始广告中的双胞胎罗德萨型号，两栋房子并排建造，
So the only way to find these houses today is literally one by one. A few weeks after I interviewed Rosemary, I went to see some of the last remaining Sears homes outside of Carro, Illinois. The town where Sears largest male had once stood. When I got there, the only sign that there had ever been anything there was the name of an overgrown back road. Sears. Leading to two tiny houses, two Sears or Odessa models, sitting next to each other. They were the twin Roadesa models from that original advertisement, with the two homes being built,
一个快，一个慢。现在它们的状态一般，但不知何故，它们比建造它们的工厂活得更久，就在西尔斯·罗巴克路上。我停下来看了一眼，30秒后，一个男人向我招手让我进去。不，坐在客厅的安乐椅上，他告诉我，他从20世纪50年代起就断断续续地住在凯罗。我大约35年前第一次看到这栋罗德萨。房子当时很破旧。我的意思是，它……屋顶漏水，窗户破了，虽然还算安全，但它很旧。
one fast, one slow, side by side. Now they were in so-so shape, but somehow they'd outlived the mill that built them here on Cirrus Roabuck Road. I stopped to take a look, and 30 seconds later a man waved me inside. No, settled into an easy chair in the living room, he told me that he'd lived on and off in caros since the 1950s. And I'd be first laid eyes on this redessa nearly 35 years ago. In the house was derelict. I mean, it was... the roof was leaking, the windows were broke out, it was still safe, but it was old.
盖伊（Guy）不久后遇到了房主，房主对他说，我把这地方卖给你，你把它修好怎么样？我说，“天哪，我什么都买不起。我一分钱都没存，这是我最后一张支票。”他说，“哦，我会让你买得起的。”他说，“15，我以15卖给你。”
Guy ran into the owner a little while later, and the owner said little while later, and the owner said to him, how about I sell you the place, and you fix it up? I said, a hell, I can't buy nothing. I said, I ain't saved a dollar, I'm my last check. He said, oh, I'll make it where you can buy it. He said, 15, I'll sell to you for 15.
我以为他说的是1000。我说，“伙计，如果它状态好的话，我会给那个价。”他说，“我说的是百。”我说，“你就在这儿等着。”所以盖伊出去了，一小时后带着现金回来，当场以1500美元买下了罗德萨。
I thought he meant 1000. I said, man, I would give that for it if it's up in shape. He said, I'm talking about hundreds. I said, you wait right here." So Guy went out, came back an hour later with the cash and bought the Rodeça for $1500 on the
最终他也买下了旁边的罗德萨。那个双胞胎，他的儿子现在住在那里。我不想这么说，但我够笨的，我在接下来的五六年里把我赚的所有钱都花在这个地方了。试图把它修好。你知道它是西尔斯的吗？
spot. Eventually he'd buy the Rodeça next to it too. The twin, his son lives there now. And I hate to say this, but I'm dumb enough that I spent everything I made
是的，我知道这些都是西尔斯的房子，因为住在拐角处的那个男人曾在西尔斯工作。他给你讲过关于工厂的故事吗？
for the next five, six years on this place. Trying to make it right. Did you know that it was a sears? that I spent everything I made for the next five, six years on this place. Trying to make it right. Did you know that it was a seer's home? Yeah, I knew all these were seers homes, because the man lived down on the corner, he worked for seers. Did he tell you any stories about the mill?
哦，是的。但他总是告诉我坏事。盖伊的邻居告诉他，工厂里的工作很辛苦，很危险。和该地区的许多工厂一样，看到员工缺手指并不罕见。当西尔斯现代住宅部门关闭时，工人们买下了工厂，并在第二次世界大战期间改制为轰炸机制造板条箱。在那之后，他们尝试以一个新的名字制造自己的套件住宅，但最终他们没能坚持下去。工厂于1955年关闭。
Oh, yeah. But he always told me the bad stuff. Guy's neighbor told him the job at the mill had been hard, dangerous work. As with a lot of mills in the area, it wasn't uncommon to see employees missing fingers. When the Sears Modern Home Department closed, the workers purchased the plant and switched to making crates for bombers during World War II. After that, they tried making their own kid homes under a new name, but ultimately they couldn't hold on. The mill closed in 1955.
在那之后他们没盖多少房子。我想尽头那栋黄色的小房子可能是他们盖的最后一栋。那只是一个小小的“猎枪屋”（shotgun house）。我妻子的妹妹在那里住到去世。即使是盖伊的房子也不再那么西尔斯了。多年来他更换了许多原始部件。看，前门？
They didn't make very many homes after that. I think this one down on the end, the little yellow house, was probably the last one they built. And it was just a little, a little shotgun house. My wife's sister lived there until she died. Even Geysouse isn't very serious anymore. He's replaced a lot of the original parts over the years. See, a front door?
这房子里唯一的东西，就在这个房间里，这个原始的，就是那扇前门。西尔斯的门。20世纪60年代，四次种族骚乱摧毁了凯罗市中心。这个城镇曾经有近100栋其他西尔斯住宅。现在，可能只剩下三分之一了。盖伊看着其余的被遗弃，或沦为瓦砾。
The only thing in this house is in this room right here, this original was that front door. The Sears door. The four series of race rides gutted downtown Kero in the 1960s. The town had nearly 100 other Sears homes. Now, maybe only a third of them are left. Guy watched us rest, or abandoned, or reduced to rubble.
市中心一直在衰落，衰落，衰落。你可以看到每个月左右就会有另一家企业消失。那里除了倒塌的破旧建筑外什么都没有。从那以后，一切都消失了。全都没了。什么都不一样了。很长一段时间里，盖伊的罗德萨小房子和它的双胞胎只是少数几个被定位和识别出来的西尔斯住宅中的两个。当盖伊买下他的房子时，西尔斯建造和
In the downtown just kept going down, going down, going down. You can see every month or so there'd be another business gone. There was nothing down there, but derelict buildings has fallen down. And since then all that's gone. It's all gone. Nothing the same. For a long time, Guy Park's little Rodeça and its twin were just two of a small handful of serious homes that had been located and identified. When Guy bought his house of the 75,000 kit homes that Sears built and
运送的75000套套件住宅中，可能只有5%得到了妥善记录，大多数都没有被发现。如果你住在西尔斯房子里，很有可能你甚至不知道。但在20多年前，一位女性朝着改变这一现状迈出了一大步。虽然，正如她自己首先承认的那样，她并不是真的打算这样做。我进入这个领域纯属偶然。这是丽贝卡·亨特（Rebecca Hunter），不，她不住在西尔斯住宅里。但她确实住在伊利诺伊州的另一端，芝加哥以西一点，在福克斯河（Fox River）上。
shipped, maybe 5% had been properly documented, most sat undiscovered. If you lived in a Sears house, chances are, you didn't even know it. But a little over 20 years ago, one woman took a big step towards changing that. Although, as she herself would be the first to admit, she didn't really mean to. It's pure serendipity that I ended up in this field. This is Rebecca Hunter, and no, she doesn't live in a seer zone. But she does live in a town on the other end of Illinois, a little west of Chicago on the Fox River.
它叫埃尔金（Elgin）。和凯罗不同，埃尔金并不以西尔斯住宅闻名。当丽贝卡在90年代中期第一次来到那里时，几乎没有人，包括她自己，知道什么是西尔斯房子。然后我的伴侣在1995年去世了，我做了所有事情，因为这有帮助。这就是丽贝卡最终来到当地图书馆的原因，在那里她偶然发现了一本关于西尔斯住宅的书，里面有各种型号的旧目录图片，这本来没什么意义，
It's called Elgin. An unlike caro, Elgin was not known for seer's homes. When Rebecca first got there in the mid-90s, almost no one there, herself included, knew what a Sears house was. Then my partner died in 1995 and I was doing everything because it helped. And that's how Rebecca ended up at the local library, where she happened upon a book about Sears Homes, which contained old catalog images of the various models, which would mean nothing,
除非在1997年2月一个寒冷刺骨的日子。那本书刚好放在餐桌上。我把它拿起来说，“哦，嘿，我想知道我能不能在我的社区走走，找到这些房子中的一栋。那会很有趣。”于是我拿起书，开始在我的社区里走。
except that one bitterly cold day in February, 1997. That book happened to be lying on the dining room table. And I picked it up and I said, oh, hi, I wonder if I could walk around my neighborhood and find one of these houses. That would be really funny. And so I picked up the book and I said about walking in my neighborhood.
你现实中期望找到多少？我没指望找到任何一栋。这真的很有趣。你知道，我有一个目标，我有一个使命，我忘记了寒冷。然后，哦，我不知道，10、15分钟后。我走在李子街（Plum Street）上，我看到了这栋房子，我立刻知道它是西尔斯的。就在那里，几乎没费什么力气，砰，一栋西尔斯房子。丽贝卡看房子，看书，看房子，看书，匹配上了。
How many were you realistically expecting to find? I wasn't expecting to find any. It was really kind of fun. You know, I had a goal, I had a mission, and I forgot about the cold. And then after, oh, I don't know, 10, 15 minutes. I was walking down Plum Street, and I saw this house and I instantly knew it was a series. Right there, after almost zero effort, boom, a series house. Reca looks the house, looks the book, looks the house, looks the book, and it's a match.
工匠风格，锥形门廊柱，阿瓦隆（Avalon）型号。然后我说，“嗯，我想知道我能不能在我的社区走走，再找一栋。”于是我做了。在一次又一次的散步中，丽贝卡不断发现西尔斯的型号。米切尔（Mitchell）、新月（Crescent）、瓦洛尼亚（Valonia），还有贝齐·罗斯（Betsy Ross）、奥斯本（Osborne）和阿罕布拉。事实上，有一条街的一侧有一个阳光（Sunlight）型号，对面是星光（Starlight）。所以你有一栋阳光和一栋星光就在街对面。但丽贝卡想确认这些确实是西尔斯
Craftsman style, tapered porch columns, the Avalon model. Then I said, huh, I wonder if I could walk around my neighborhood and find another one. And so I did. On walk, after walk, Rebecca kept finding Sears models. The Mitchell, the Crescent, the Valonia, Then there was the Betsy Ross, the Osborne, and the Alhambra. In fact, there's one street that has a sunlight model on one side of the street, and the opposite is the starlight. So you have a sunlight and a starlight right across the street from each other. But Rebecca wanted to confirm that these were Sears
住宅。所以她寄出了一份邮件，要求每位居民去检查地下室。当他们这样做时，大多数人发现了带有西尔斯零件编号的特殊印章的横梁。其他人发现了阁楼底板背面的西尔斯装运标签。还有一些人设法找到了他们房子原始的西尔斯蓝图。丽贝卡甚至还没做完。还有更多的房子等着被调查。埃尔金总共有多少栋房子？目前，我想我们有237栋西尔斯住宅，还有大约100栋来自其他公司。
Homes. So she sent a mailer out, asking each resident to go and inspect the basement. When they did, most discovered beams bearing a special stamp with a part number from Sears. Others found shipping labels from Sears on the back of attic baseports. Still others managed to find their home's original Sears blueprints. And Rebecca's not even done. There are still more houses waiting to be investigated. What did the total number of houses in Elgin and Bupi? At the moment, I think we are at 237 Sears houses and about 100 from other companies.
更重要的是，大多数被发现的房子看起来就像直接从目录里出来的一样。自20世纪20年代以来，它们几乎没有被改变过。这就是为什么她能找到这么多，因为这些房子仍然可以被识别出来。而且有一个具体的原因。当雇佣了全镇四分之一人口的埃尔金手表厂（Elgin Watch Factory）在1964年关闭时，埃尔金进入了局部衰退，使其免于60年代和70年代的翻新热潮。相反，埃尔金的西尔斯住宅只是在几十年里保持原样。
What's more, most of the homes were back-of-found, looked like they were straight out of the catalog. They had barely been altered since the 1920s. That's why she was able to find so many because the homes could still be recognized. And there was a specific reason why. When the Elgin Watch Factory, which had employed a quarter of the town closed in 1964, Elgin entered a localized recession, sparing it from the renovation craze of the 60s and 70s. Instead, Elgin Sears' home simply sat there through the decades untouched.
有没有人指出过手表厂的关闭将这些房子冻结在时间里的事实？哦，是的，我们谈论过这个。如果我们喜欢它，我们就喜欢它。丽贝卡对埃尔金住宅的研究，加上其他研究人员如建筑历史学家罗斯·桑顿的工作，将有助于发起一场已经成为西尔斯住宅搜寻运动的活动。那些人生主要热情就是搜寻这片土地，试图找到尽可能多的套件住宅的人，包括罗斯。有些人做填字游戏，有些人做拼图游戏。
Does anyone ever point out the fact that the closing of the watch factory froze the houses in time? Oh yeah, we talk about that. If we love it, we love it. Rebecca's study of the Elgin Homes, along with the work of other researchers like Rose Thornton, our architectural historian, would help to launch what has become a Sears house hunting movement. People whose chief passion in life is to scour the land, trying to find as many kid homes as possible, including Rose. Some people do crossword puzzles, and some people do jigsaw puzzles.
我想我是在寻找西尔斯住宅。好吧，实际上，你可能在罗斯、戴尔、温迪、安德鲁、奈杰尔和辛迪那里寻找西尔斯住宅。这些名字构成了西尔斯住宅搜寻者精英核心的一部分，如果可以的话，是一个团队。像任何正规的A队一样，每个成员都有自己的专长。罗斯玛丽搜寻罕见的西尔斯木兰，那栋三层殖民地豪宅。到目前为止，她说他们找到了10栋。戴尔·沃尔基（Dale Wolkey）专门研究西尔斯最大的竞争对手阿拉丁公司（Aladdin Company）建造的套件住宅。而安德鲁·马奇（Andrew Mutch）是数字专家。他目前正与大约六个人合作建立一个数据库，列出每一个西尔斯住宅。
I guess I look for Sears homes. Well, actually, you may in Rose and Dale and Wendy and Andrew and Nigel and Cindy look for Sears Houses. Those names form part of an elite core of the Sears house hunters and a team if you will. And like any proper a team, each member has their specialty. Rosemary hunts for the rare Sears Magnolia, the three-story colonial mansion. So far she says says. They found 10. Dale Wolkey specializes in kid homes built by Sears biggest competitor, the Aladdin company. And Andrew Mutch is the numbers guy. He's currently working with about half a dozen people on a database that would list every single Sears.
与此同时，19岁的奈杰尔·泰特（Nigel Tate）是他们团队中最年轻的成员。他甚至没离开过书桌就找到了1000多栋套件住宅。他使用谷歌街景。但大多数时候，他们用老式的方法搜寻房子，追寻线索，一起开车巡逻美国的街道。安德鲁在前面，他有他的电脑，他在写下地址。戴尔在开车，温迪和我在后座，
Meanwhile Nigel Tate at 19 is the youngest member of their team. He's found over 1,000 kid homes without even leaving his desk. He uses Google Street View. But mostly, they hunt for houses the old fashioned way, chasing down clues and patrolling the mean streets of America in a car together. And Andrew's up in front, and he's got his computer, and he's writing down addresses. And Dale is striving, and Wendy and I are in the back seat
每个人都拿着相机。每个人都在往窗外看，有人说，“嘿，右边那个是什么？”虽然，让我们面对现实吧，他们并不完全是赏金猎人。所以我下车拍照，这个非常高大、愤怒的男人冲出前门。他手里拿着一根棒球棍。如果我们上车，我们就跑。
each with a camera. And everybody's looking out the window and somebody says, hey, what's that over there on the right? Although, let's face it, they're not exactly bounty hunters. And so I'm getting out and I'm taking pictures and this very large, angry man bursts out the front door. He has a baseball bat in his hand. If we get in the car and we take off.
除了偶尔的失误，罗斯和丽贝卡认为，他们和其他住宅搜寻者已经帮助识别了来自西尔斯和其他公司的近50000栋套件住宅。所以，下次当一队拿着相机、笔记本电脑和旧西尔斯目录的杂牌研究人员敲你的门，问他们是否可以快速参观一下你的地下室时，不要害怕。他们是来帮忙的。谁知道呢，你甚至可能正站在一个未被发现的型号里。你见过西尔斯校舍吗？因为我看到他们有一年提供过那个。哦，是的，我找那个找了很久了。天哪。我一直在像找工作一样搜寻那个东西。西尔斯住宅是点缀在景观中的唯一西尔斯建筑吗？
The occasional misstep aside, Rosenwebekah think that they and other house hunters have helped identify nearly 50,000 kid homes from seers and other companies. So the next time a rag tag team of researchers armed with cameras, laptops, and an old seers catalog knocks on your door and asks if they can take a quick tour of your basement. Don't be frightened. They're there to help. And who knows, you might even be standing in an undiscovered model. Have you ever seen a series schoolhouse because I saw that they offered that one year? Oh yeah, I've been looking for that a long time. Good lord. I've been hunting that thing down like it's my job. Sirus Holmes on the only Sirus architecture dotting the landscape.
库尔特和我将在之后讨论美国各地大型西尔斯建筑的适应性再利用。["世界香肠"] 在库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）加入《99%隐形》团队的前几年，我和他开始通过电子邮件通信。除其他事项外，他有时会发来故事创意。其中之一是关于他搬进明尼阿波利斯的一栋旧西尔斯建筑。那不是西尔斯住宅。那是西尔斯工厂，一个巨大的城市街区大小的仓库、配送中心和零售
Kurt and I talk about the adaptive reuse of massive Sears buildings all across the US, after this. ["Susages of the World"] Years before Kurt Colstead joined the team at 99% in visible, he and I started corresponding by email. Among other things, he sometimes sent over story ideas. And one of those was about an old Sears building he moved into in Minneapolis. It's not a Sears home. It's a Sears plant, a huge city block sized warehouse, distribution center, and retail
商店。是的，当我真的很小的时候，我实际上经常去这个地方购物。那是一栋12层的装饰艺术风格西尔斯大楼。我和父母一起去那里。但在我在明尼苏达州的那些年里，它只是一栋废弃的建筑。我曾经沿着这条杂草丛生的铁轨走过几英里，铁轨在沟渠里经过这栋建筑。当时，那个庞大的建筑群是一种不祥的存在，你骑自行车经过时只会匆匆溜过，你知道，不要靠得太近。
store. Yeah, and when I was really young, I used to actually go shopping in this thing. It was this 12 story Art Deco Sears. I'd go there with my parents. But for most of my years in Minnesota, it was just an abandoned building. I used to have, like, for miles along this overgrown railroad track that ran past the building in a trench. And at the time, that big complex was kind of this ominous presence that you just kind of slip past on your bike and you know, not get too close to you.
所以你基本上根本不与它互动。它不是那种你会走过去的地方，你只是快速骑车经过它。是的。是的。它只是，你知道，它占据了多个城市街区。所以它真的有点，你知道，在停车场和建筑之间，它只是城市中一个巨大的、空旷的存在。没错。然后突然，你知道，多年后我搬回了中西部，这个地方完全变了。它被重新命名为中城交易所（Midtown Exchange），主楼层挤满了所有这些小商店和餐馆，上面还有办公室、公寓和共管公寓。我曾经骑车经过的那些旧铁轨已经被清理、铺平，变成了这条五英里的绿道，这真的很棒，这是一种现成的“铁路变步道”改造。
So you basically don't engage with it at all. It's not really something like you go up to, you just cycle past it quickly. Yeah. Yeah. It's just, you know, and it took a multiple city block. So it was really kind of, you know, between the parking lot and the building, it was just this big, empty presence in the city. Right. And then suddenly, you know, I moved back to the Midwest years later, and this place is totally transformed. It had been renamed the Midtown Exchange, and it was full of all these little shops and eateries on the main floor, plus offices and apartments and condos above. And those old rail tracks that I'd biked along had been cleared and paved and turned into this five mile greenway, which was really neat, it's sort of this ready-made rails to trails conversion.
我对此非常感兴趣，不仅是作为一栋建筑，而且作为一种城市现象，比如他们是如何把这个“无”再次变成“有”的。所以作为一个建筑极客，我自然开始挖掘西尔斯的历史。那么你在研究中发现了什么？嗯，首先，理查德·沃伦·西尔斯（Richard Warren Sears）本人出生在明尼苏达州，他在19世纪末实际上在那里开始销售手表。后来，随着时间的推移，他把业务转移到了芝加哥，并开始扩大这个更大的邮购业务。它基本上成为了20世纪初的亚马逊。在20世纪20年代，
And I got really interested in this, not just as a building, but also as an urban phenomena, like how they'd turned this nothing into a something again. So I naturally, being an architecture geek, started digging into the history of seers. So what did you find in your research? Well, for starters, Richard Warren Sears himself was born in Minnesota, where he actually started something watches in the late 1800s. Then over time, he moved operations to Chicago and started growing out this larger mail order business. And it basically became the Amazon of the early 20th century. And in the 1920s,
他们开始更多地扩张，从波士顿到西雅图，在他们的配送中心增加了零售网点。你给我看过这些照片。它们看起来惊人地相似，尽管它们散布在整个美国。它们有一些不同的砖块风格，但它们都显得有点方方正正，它们有大窗户和其他共同的细节，包括这些非常棒的、独特的装饰艺术风格塔楼。
they started branching out even more, adding retail outlets to their distribution centers all the way from Boston to Seattle. And you've shown me pictures of these. They all look surprisingly similar, even though they're scattered across the entire US. They have some different brick styles, but they're all kind of boxy, they have big windows and other details in common, including these really great distinctive art deco style towers.
是的，它们看起来有点像城堡塔楼之类的，如果你在搜寻这类西尔斯建筑，它们是一个很大的线索。它们也发挥了功能。它们基本上隐藏了这些巨大的供水系统，然后为下面的楼层服务。是的，一旦你知道了塔楼和这些其他细节，你就可以很容易地开始在其他城市发现其他塔楼。
Yeah, they look a little bit like castle towers or something, and they're a big giveaway if you're hunting these kinds of serious buildings. And they serve to function too. They basically concealed these huge water systems that then serve the floors below. And yeah, once you know the towers and these other details, you can really easily start to spot other towers
而这种共同点很大程度上可以追溯到一位特定的建筑师，乔治·克劳威尔·尼明斯（George Crowell Nimmons）。他为西尔斯做了很多工作。他甚至在某个时候为公司总裁设计了一座豪宅，但他主要以大型商业作品而闻名。除其他事项外，他参与了这个非常大的、
in other cities. And a lot of that commonality traces back to this one architect in particular, George Crowell Nimins. And he did a lot of work for Sears. He even designed it one point, a mansion for the company's president, but he's mostly known for his big scale commercial work. And among other things, he worked on this really big,
早期的计划，一个西尔斯在芝加哥的行政中心。但这并不是芝加哥的西尔斯大厦，或者现在的威利斯大厦（Willis Tower）。它是别的东西。没错，没错。那实际上是几十年后才出现的，但令人惊讶的是，它只有这个没人真正知道的旧建筑群的一半大。旧建筑群建在市中心以西一点，大约有300万平方英尺。
early plan, an administrative hub for Sears in Chicago. But this is not the Sears tower of Chicago, or the now Willow's tower. It's something else. Right, right. That actually came many decades later, but amazingly, it was only half again as big as this really old complex, but nobody really knows about. The old complex was built a bit west of downtown and it was about 3 million square feet.
该公司吹嘘它是当时世界上最大的商业建筑群，它跨越了多个街区。它覆盖了现有的街道。所以它实际上阻断了城市街道。当然，他们必须获得城市的特别许可才能这样做。这个地方基本上像城中之城一样运作。它有自己的发电厂。它有自己的企业员工消防队。它甚至有自己的广播电台WLS，即“世界最大商店”（World's Largest Store）的缩写。我喜欢它有自己的商业广播电台，这太棒了。是的，我的意思是他们厌倦了在其他广播电台购买播出时间，最终他们
The company boasted that it was the largest commercial complex in the world at the time, and it spanned multiple blocks. It covered existing streets. So it actually blocked off city streets. And they had to get special permission, of course, from the city to do that. And the place basically functions like a city within the city. It had its own power plant. It had its own corporate, you know, employee-based fire department. And it even had its own radio station WLS short for world's largest store. I love that it had its own commercial radio station that's so great. Yeah, I mean they got sick of basically buying airtime on other radio stations and eventually they're
就像，“嘿，你知道吗？我们自己开个广播电台吧。”当然。因为你知道当时西尔斯是这个巨人。它是美国最大的零售商，而且他们一直在扩张。他们一直跟随国家带他们去的地方。起初，他们做邮购，服务农村人口。然后他们增加了这些混合用途的工厂和零售网点来服务城市。然后随着人们搬到郊区，他们开始进入这些购物中心。今天，显然，西尔斯表现得不太好。例如，芝加哥的那个建筑群中有很多
like, hey, you know what? We'll just start on a radio station. Of course. Because you know at the time series is this giant. It's America's biggest retailer, and they just kept expanding too. They kept following where the country took them. At first, they did mail order where they served rural populations. Then they added these mixed-use plants with retail outlets to serve cities. Then as people moved out to the suburbs, they began to go into these shopping centers. Today, obviously, the series is not doing quite as well. And a lot of that complex in Chicago, for example,
已经被拆除了。但有些部分仍然存在。而且你们中有些人还没有被重新利用，包括那个标志性的中央塔楼。因为在城市里重新利用一百多万平方英尺真的很难。是的，这极其困难。而且几乎不可能找到单一的企业客户。
has been torn down. But some parts are still around. And some of you haven't been reused, including that central iconic tower. Because it's really hard to reuse a million plus square feet inside of a city. Yeah, it's incredibly difficult. And almost impossible to find a single corporate client
已经被拆除了。但有些部分依然存在。还有一些没有被重新利用，包括那座标志性的中央塔楼。因为在城市内部重新利用一百多万平方英尺的空间确实非常困难。是的，这极其困难。而且几乎不可能找到单一的企业客户。
who could take that on and So like the one in Minneapolis for instance, it had to bring in all these different stakeholders, you know a local hospital And get the city on board and other developers so that you know There was a plan to make it mixed use from the start But these buildings also have some advantages too for adaptive reuse You know they're built of sturdy concrete and masonry, and they get a lot of light on all sides because they have these huge windows. And so when you wrote me years and years and years ago,
谁能承担起这个任务呢？比如明尼阿波利斯的那个项目，它必须引入所有这些不同的利益相关者，你知道，包括当地医院，还要让市政府和其他开发商参与进来，这样从一开始就有一个混合用途的规划。但这些建筑在适应性再利用方面也有一些优势，你知道它们是用坚固的混凝土和砖石建造的，而且因为有巨大的窗户，四面采光都很好。所以当你多年前给我写信时，
it was in part a story about how cities are reusing these serious buildings. Yeah, and that's what really fascinating to be the most. It's not just that they're being reused, but it's the stories that they tell about the different cities they're being reused in. So in some ways, it's like this big urban experiment. If you put these different boxes that all kind of the same
这在某种程度上是一个关于城市如何再利用这些大型建筑的故事。是的，这对我来说最令人着迷。不仅仅是它们被再利用了，而是它们讲述了在不同城市中被再利用的故事。所以在某种程度上，这就像是一个巨大的城市实验。如果你把这些不同的盒子，它们看起来都差不多，
and are all sort of similar in size, and you spread them out across the country and you abandon them, what happens? Right. And it turns out that you get these very city-specific stories of abandonment and reuse that tell you something about these different places. Yeah. Okay, so what are some of your favorites? What did you discover? Well, in Seattle, famous for a long time, it was basically
而且大小也相似，你把它们分散到全国各地，然后废弃它们，会发生什么呢？没错。结果发现，你会得到这些非常具有城市特色的废弃与再利用的故事，它们能告诉你关于这些不同地方的一些信息。是的。好的，那么你最喜欢的一些是什么？你发现了什么？嗯，在西雅图，长期以来很有名，它基本上
down to just the retail store on the ground floor, and the rest of the building was empty. But of course, even an empty building when you're talking about Hollywood has a function. You can rent it out for filming. So it became a filming location. And then a lot of cities sort of followed the Minneapolis example. And Boston was the first one to do it where they just said, you know, we have to bring in a bunch of different programs to make this work for our cities. So they, you know, had theaters and sports complexes and daycare centers and Memphis and Minneapolis and other cities follow it soon.
只剩下底层的零售店，其余部分都是空的。但当然，当你谈论好莱坞时，即使是一栋空建筑也有它的功能。你可以把它租出去用于拍摄。所以它成了一个拍摄地点。然后许多城市效仿了明尼阿波利斯的例子。波士顿是第一个这样做的城市，他们说，你知道，我们必须引入一系列不同的项目来让它为我们的城市服务。所以他们，你知道，有了剧院、体育中心和日托中心，孟菲斯、明尼阿波利斯和其他城市也很快跟进了。
And so there's a little Sears building in Uptown, Oakland, what we call Uptown, is if you drive up telegraph or away from beautiful downtown Oakland, California, towards beautiful Uptown, or if you're going to go for exactly, you'll see a little one, and what did they use that one for? So that place is really small, and it's called the telegraph lofts,
在奥克兰上城区，也就是我们所说的上城区，有一栋小小的西尔斯大楼。如果你沿着电报大道从美丽的加州奥克兰市中心往美丽的奥克兰上城区开，或者如果你要去那里，你会看到一个小一点的，他们把它用作什么了呢？那个地方真的很小，叫做电报阁楼，
and basically they're live work units, so they're residential units, and there's some self-storage and other stuff, but mainly it's residential. Which is probably the thing we need the most in the Bay Area. Oh yeah, yeah, if there are empty buildings to be reused here, I would hope we could just turn them all into more housing. Amen. Alright. Thanks, Kurt.
基本上它们是居住工作单元，也就是住宅单元，还有一些自助仓储之类的东西，但主要是住宅。这可能是我们在湾区最需要的东西。哦，是的，是的，如果这里有空建筑可以再利用，我希望我们能把它们全部变成更多的住房。阿门。好的。谢谢你，库尔特。
Yeah. 99% of his work was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg and Kurt Colstad, mixed in 2018 by Sharif Yisif, music by our director of sound, Swan Rihau. Delaney Hall is the executive producer at the rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Lashemadon, Chris Baroubaix, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. In this story, you also heard the voices of past 99 PI producers, Avery Trouffleman and Katie Mingle. What's nice hearing them? We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM Podcast family.
是的。本周99%的节目由乔·罗森伯格和库尔特·科尔斯塔德制作，2018年由谢里夫·伊西夫混音，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里豪制作。德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，团队其他成员包括薇薇安·勒、拉舍马顿、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我，罗曼·马斯。在这个故事中，你还听到了过去99 PI制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和凯蒂·明格的声音。听到他们的声音真好。我们是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分。
Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. Maybe you can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at nine on PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of this year program 99PI at 99PI.org. I will always call it the Sears Tower. Never the Willis Tower. Stitcher Series X.
现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加州奥克兰上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。也许你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI.org。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI节目的每一集往期内容。我永远会叫它西尔斯大厦。永远不会叫它威利斯大厦。Stitcher Series X。
always call it the Sears Tower, never the Willis Tower. Stitcher, Sears X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
永远叫它西尔斯大厦，永远不要叫它威利斯大厦。Stitcher，西尔斯X。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。